[Music]
on this friday night
rolling back to the red zone tougher
restrictions return to some
ontario regions we're staring down the
barrel of another
lockdown as saskatchewan beefs up its
battle
it feels like covet is crushing in from
all sides
the pandemic pressure the prime minister
promises to help provinces
but there's a catch and have a merry
pandemic
i think santa probably has immunity the
new take
on joy to the world
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
we begin tonight with the pandemic it's
been a week of record-breaking numbers
in many parts of this country and the
models show the cases of kova 19
may only get worse bc hit another record
with 617 new infections
and today ontario announced it is
lowering the thresholds for imposing
tougher measures
the change means more regions will move
into red alert mode
this is the most restrictive level short
of a lockdown
and today premier doug ford warned he
won't hesitate to move the province in
that direction
again i will lock down quicker than you
can blink your eyes
because my number one priority is to
protect
that lives protect the safety of every
single person
in ontario eric sorensen reports on how
ontario is changing course to curb the
rapid reach
of the virus not only is the pandemic
hitting harder than in the spring
canadians and government leaders have
been more resistant to locking down this
time
but with disturbing new forecasts of
rising cases and hospitalizations
comes a new tone from one premier doug
ford
family should not i repeat not visit any
other households
or allow visitors to their homes
and please avoid social gatherings
and there will be an impact on more
restaurants and other businesses across
the province
ontario has changed the threshold for
restrictions from four regions under
intermediate and stringent measures
to more than a dozen now deemed in the
orange and red zones
we're staring down the barrel of another
lockdown
and i will not hesitate for a second
if we have to go further from a low of
fewer than 100 cases per day in august
a sharp rise this month to an average of
more than 1350 confirmed cases per day
over the last week ontario's modeling
consensus says that could rise to 6 500
per day by mid-december
if left unchecked a circuit breaker a
hard brief lockdown to break the chains
of transmission
could reduce the spread noticeably but
how far down the numbers go
would depend on many factors how severe
the restrictions
how long they would last the measures
have to do more than bring case numbers
down temporarily say experts or else
they'll just go up again when the
restrictions are lifted
it's something like circuit break or
general lockdown is to be used
we've got to be crystal clear as to what
the goals are
and if the goal is to secure testing
contact tracing
then we need to meet that goal a long
hard winter was always expected but
canadians are tired of the pandemic
and their tolerance will be tested which
is better which is more tolerable
a series of lockdowns or one hard
lockdown
any strategy from the government down
needs buy-in from the public
and so ultimately this is always in the
hands of the public how much are we
willing to restrict
our average numbers of contacts in
ontario the hope is to avoid a total
lockdown to keep schools open
give most businesses some flexibility
and see how things go
as christmas approaches eric sorensen
global news
toronto the prairie provinces are
struggling to deal with rising covet 19
cases
manitoba and alberta have already
brought in tougher restrictions and
today
saskatchewan followed suit but as
roberta bell reports not everyone feels
the new rules
go far enough i'm not going to sugarcoat
the situation
it's not great and it's been getting
worse
a bleak warning from saskatchewan's
health minister
with more than 1400 active cases in the
province
81 of them knew friday at the rate
things are going
officials say the health care system
will not be able to keep up
what we feared what could happen
is starting to happen and we have a very
unique opportunity right now to be able
to flatten that curve again
the minister says a slowdown is
necessary to avoid a lockdown
announcing new measures under a public
health order
expanding the mask mandate from the
three biggest cities to all communities
with populations over 5
000 limiting alcohol sales at
restaurants and bars
last call will be at 10 o'clock and
people will have to finish their drinks
by 11
and capping group fitness classes at
eight people
we are watching what's happening in
alberta
we are watching what's happening in
manitoba
we are watching what's happening just
south of the border to us
and it feels like covet is crushing in
from all sides
after hearing the restrictions a group
of doctors who wrote a letter this week
asking the province to clamp down
say unfortunately the additional
interventions announced today
do not go far enough i'm terrified
and i i think that is the word that i
would use i lose sleep at night
i worry about my children i worry about
my parents
i worry about my colleagues we've
seen this cyrus [ __ ] healthcare
systems across the world
the business community is pleased
there's no shutdown but the president of
regina's chamber of commerce
wants people to follow the rules
saskatchewan's chief medical health
officer says if we can't limit
transmission
then we could see more restrictions
coming in these ones though
will begin monday and be in place until
at least december 4th
robin roberta bell in regina thanks
roberta
there are tighter measures in parts of
canada's north today nunavut confirmed
its fourth case in a week
prior to november 6th it hadn't recorded
a single infection
the territory is putting more
restrictions on gatherings and
non-essential travel in iqaluit
and the region akavalek prime minister
justin trudeau has told the country's
premiers they can count on ottawa's help
through the next phase of the pandemic
but the pledge comes with a caveat as
david aiken is here to tell us that
involves taking aggressive steps to stem
the spread
david well robin on tuesday prime
minister justin trudeau challenged
premiers
to do more to meet the looming health
crisis
and they responded one premier after
another this week announced new
lockdowns
and new restrictions now they need more
federal help
manitoba asked for and will get federal
help to run
some of its long-term care facilities
the canadian red cross
is already on the ground assessing the
situation and is working with local and
provincial authorities
to determine their specific needs quebec
2 asks for
and will get an extension on a federal
program that helps
that province with its long-term care
facilities
but will the plans put in place by each
premier bee
enough trudeau said it was not up to him
to judge
those are questions that quite
appropriately are are to be asked by
citizens
in the provinces meanwhile more grim
numbers
now more than 10 700 deaths in canada
from covet 19
and an average daily new case count that
is at 4 300 and
curving upwards if we continue on the
current pace
it is estimated that there will be over
10 000 cases daily
by early december and without flattening
that curve
the chance of a normal christmas will
disappear
right now is not looking good
but the lockdowns needed to flatten that
curve will inevitably cause
economic harm so to ease that pain
trudeau announced an additional
1.5 billion dollars for skills training
to help those who will need to find new
jobs we have to do our part
to flatten the curve before it gets any
worse
and ottawa will be asked to spend even
more
prime minister justin trudeau and the
premiers will meet in early december
where the provinces will press for
permanent and significant
increases in federal health transfers
robin
david aiken in ottawa thanks david for
the first time since the november 3rd
election
u.s president donald trump has addressed
the country about the worsening
covenanting pandemic
the u.s centers for disease control and
prevention is predicting that within the
next four weeks
deaths could climb as high as 282
thousand
as jennifer johnson reports mayors and
governors even in conservative states
are now taking drastic measures to slow
the spread
with new cases of cobit 19 skyrocketing
u.s president donald trump broke his
silence to update americans
on operation warp speed the effort to
get a vaccine to market
fast we will work to secure an emergency
use authorization
which should be coming down extremely
soon and my administration will then
coordinate
the distribution of the vaccine the
virus is sweeping across america
including at the white house
where over 130 secret service members
are either infected or in quarantine
desperate state leaders even in
conservative states are pleading for the
public's help
i've issued a mass mandate in arkansas
but we want to increase compliance
illinois wisconsin and indiana are
reporting a new positive case every four
seconds
chicago's mayor has issued a 30-day
stay-at-home advisory starting monday
cobia 19 positive nurses in north dakota
who are asymptomatic
are being asked to return to work to
treat infected patients this is kind of
like standing on the beach and watching
the hurricane slowly
roll towards you in an interview with
cbs this morning the nation's top
infectious disease expert says americans
have to be careful
over the holiday season there is light
at the end of the tunnel so the message
to the american people is please hang in
there and
implement the public health measures
because help
is on the way bars in 11 california
counties
closing again disneyland shut down until
2021
ivy league colleges have called off all
winter sports no more indoor eating for
many missouri restaurants
we've been planning for carryout if we
have to but again it's not
it's not sustainable for our overhead
our rent our
utilities president-elect joe biden's
coronavirus task force is already
working
but since president trump hasn't
conceded the election yet
biden's team says it's being denied
access to key planning with the
department of health
as it prepares a vaccination campaign
starting as early as january
jennifer johnson global news washington
china has congratulated u.s
president-elect joe
biden one of the last countries to
acknowledge his electoral victory over
donald trump
during a press conference today a
foreign ministry spokesperson commended
the democratic candidate
and his running mate kamala harris he
gave no reason for china's delay but
said quote
we respect the choice of the american
people under the trump administration
the u.s china relationship reached its
lowest point
in decades biden promises to remain
tough on beijing
but seek a united front a tent situation
is unfolding in montreal tonight there's
a large police operation
underway near the offices of video game
maker ubisoft
it's located at a busy intersection and
police have cordoned off the area
they're asking people to stay away dan
spector is there for us tonight dan what
have you learned about the situation
well robin it's a very busy intersection
indeed here at saint viatar
and saint laurent boulevard just steps
away from the famous st theater bagel
shop it's a very
bustling and busy neighborhood and
police have been sprawled out around
here
all afternoon they have brought just
about every unit you could think of the
swat team was here
the motorcycles were here even the
horses were here an armored vehicle
and their attention all afternoon has
been focused on
ubisoft now what they've been doing is
gradually ushering people out of the
building
and this all began at around one o'clock
when they got a call about a possible
armed robbery and the police came people
had been
hiding inside i spoke to the sister of
one ubisoft employee
who said her sister had hidden in a
conference room others
hid on the roof because nobody knew
exactly what level of threat they were
facing
but meanwhile police have been slowly
and gradually sweeping the building
and bringing people out and what they've
discovered is nothing they found
no threat they have no suspect so now
the question is
who made this call and what is the thing
that
prompted this huge police presence but
as of now
no suspect and no threat just for all of
this police presence
back to you robin dan spectre montreal
thanks dan
the toll of kova 19 coming up what
health care workers
are being forced to deal with now plus
diwali with a dose of the pandemic
this don't wait for the government to
tell you what to do
do the right thing now calgary's mayor
is encouraging people to take
immediate action to contain the spread
of kova 19 before the alberta government
has to put more restrictions in place
907 new cases were confirmed today in
that province
the second highest daily count of the
pandemic
many of us have covered 19 fatigue but
those on the front lines have a message
this disease isn't going away health
care workers have the burden of taking
care of the sick
and in some cases watching them die but
their own lives are
also on the line here's heather yorks
west
each night it was a chance to say thank
you a noisy salute to the health care
workers treating covet 19 patients on
the front lines
but eight months into this pandemic in
the thick of a second wave
calgary doctor joe vaipond doesn't hear
those nightly tributes and more
back in the spring there was this
feeling that all of society was behind
us that yes you are
are endangering yourselves but you know
what we're all willing to
to to step up and play our part and and
i think the the harder part for us today
is we no longer have that sense
of solidarity with the rest of society
instead doctors in several provinces
feel at odds with policymakers
who are now balancing economic concerns
with the issues around public health we
really have a recipe of number one
psychological and emotional trauma and
number two
risk of them getting sick or being
quarantined according to the canadian
institute for health information more
than 21 000 health workers were infected
with culvin 19
during the country's first wave 12 of
those workers
died since then there have been another
915
infections among health workers in bc
more than 1800 in alberta
69 in saskatchewan 2096 in ontario
and more than 7 000 in quebec where
another 10 health workers have died
physicians
are tired the canadian medical
association says it's time for the
country to return to the mindset we had
last spring
so we're eight months into this pandemic
and canadians are
uh on the whole are are tired of hearing
about it um but the fact remains
that this is a virus that kills people
and we're seeing that now and with
hospitals in several parts of the
country
approaching capacity the need for a
fresh
sense of solidarity has never been so
great
heather urex west global news calgary
elon musk is questioning the accuracy of
covet 19 tests after testing positive
and negative in the same day the ceo of
tesla says something bogus is going on
after claiming he was tested four times
with different results
he tweeted two tests came back negative
two came back positive
same machine same test same nurse
musk took rapid antigen tests yesterday
and is now awaiting results from pcr
tests
the ones most commonly used in canada he
says he has symptoms
of a typical cold the miami marlins have
hired the league's first female and
first asian american gm
it's believed kim ing is the first
female gm for any major men's sports
league in north america
the 51 year old entered the baseball
business as an intern in 1990.
in a statement she says it seemed
unlikely a woman would lead a major
league team
but i am dogged in the pursuit of my
goals
still ahead a somber anniversary five
years after france's
deadliest terror attack
you're watching global national
the united nations is warning the
conflict in ethiopia is on the verge of
spiraling out of control
government troops and forces loyal to
insurgent leaders in the tigray region
have been fighting for the last 10 days
hundreds of people have been killed and
more than 14 000
others have fled to nearby sudan
despite the severing of communications
with tigre making it difficult to verify
the extent of the damage so far
we've received reports from a variety of
sources suggesting increased air strikes
by government forces as well as fierce
ground fighting between the opposing
forces
the world agency is calling for a full
investigation into reports of mass
killings of civilians based on ethnicity
if the allegations are proven they could
be deemed
war crimes it's now been five years
since the worst terror attack to ever
strike france
somber ceremonies were held in paris
today france's prime minister along with
other dignitaries laid wreaths at the
sites of the rampage
on november 13 2015 three groups under
the banner of the so-called islamic
state
attacked the bataclan theater cafes and
the national stadium
130 people were killed 350 were injured
france is now under high alert for
terrorist threats there have been three
attacks by islamic extremists since
september
which killed four people
up next as the pandemic worsens in
europe is there still
hope for the holidays
india is illuminated with dazzling
displays for diwali
the five-day festival is usually the
biggest holiday a time to mark the
triumph of good over evil
it's celebrated by hindus sikhs jains
and buddhists worldwide
and one city ignored kova 19
restrictions to keep its guinness world
record
for most lights thousands of volunteers
lit over 584 000
oil lamps at many malls across this
country
the magical in-person experience with
saint nick will be replaced with a
virtual visit from santa's headquarters
in the north pole that's one holiday
tradition taking on a twist in 2020.
the prime minister says the way
canadians behave now will determine
how we can celebrate christmas and
there's a similar sentiment in europe
whereas redmond shannon reports there's
no guarantee of getting
home for the holidays
no one does christmas quite like the
germans but this year one traditional
market is more about
cars than carols
welcome to the drive-through christmas
market
this is as good as it gets when
everything else is closed
says this man a similar situation in
london
is dampening expectations for
celebrations
and i want as many londoners as possible
to have
a christmas although not like any other
christmas they've had before
but one that's semi-decent the promise
of a semi-decent festive season is a
deal that much of europe will have to
accept right now
the hope is that these november
lockdowns will be the key
to making that happen not objective
but france's prime minister says it's
still too early to be booking
any train tickets i think in terms of
people booking flights for christmas to
come home uh
i'd advise him not to do that at the
moment i know that's difficult i know
that's tough
a similar message in ireland i mean i'm
gonna be swimming
home if that's if that's what it comes
to i can't see them banning travel it's
not gonna be illegal
they're not going to be arresting people
at the airport immigrant ina quinn says
many people will travel no matter what
governments say
it just seems pretty wild that there's
no
plan in place you know there's a matter
of weeks to go now so
it's just really frustrating in canada
the holidays will also be different
but at least one thing has been
guaranteed by bc's top doctor
i think santa probably has immunity and
we'll look at how
we can facilitate him i think he'll be
washing his hands a lot and he probably
won't be eating cookies and milk
in every house this year but we'll find
ways of making it work
we're unlikely to ever forget christmas
2020
even if some of us will want to redmond
shannon global news
london and that is global national for
this friday i'm robin gill
we leave you tonight with the snow on
cypress mountain in british columbia
the popular resort reopened for the
winter season today of course there are
pandemic safety measures
for snowboarders and skiers thank you
for watching
i'll see you back here tomorrow have a
great night